26 février dernier c'est dans un
laconique communiqué de presse que le
procureur de tours a présenté son
réquisitoire il demande le renvoi de
véronique courjault devant les assises
pour assassinats mais surtout le non
lieu pour jean louis courjault mercredi
dernier la juge d'instruction boulard
paolini confirmait dans son ordonnance
le non-lieu pour jean louis courjault et
le laver ainsi de tout soupçon ce
jour-là pour la première fois depuis la
mise en examen de son épouse jean louis
courjault apparaissait à la presse
visiblement très ému c'est un
soulagement pour tout le monde mais
d'abord pour mes enfants qui ont
beaucoup souffert de tout ça qui
qui sont contents de voir leur père
innocenté
après tout ce qu'ils ont pu entendre ou
voir
c'est aussi un grand soulagement parce
que je vais pouvoir me consacrer
entièrement à soutenir ma femme que
j'aime
et on va la soutenir a trop avec mes
enfants
qui n'attendent qu'une seule chose c'est
son retour
voilà il faut reconstruire c'est tout ce
que je vous dis aujourd'hui ni marc
morin avocat de jean louis courjault ni
philippe varin le procureur de tours ne
souhaitait faire de commentaire sur cet
appel d'ici trois semaines une audience
publique se tiendra devant la chambre
d'instruction selon un communiqué la
procureure générale d'orléans souhaite
ainsi assurer sur cette décision un
double regard par une formation
collégiale
après examen du dossier la chambre
d'instruction pourrait soit confirmé le
non-lieu soit complété le dossier
d'instruction en demandant d'autres
expertises soient estimé que les charges
sont suffisantes pour renvoyer jean
louis courjault devant la cour d'assises
pour complicité d'assassinât